はい 先生 はい この心の話をする時に 3つの例えがあるんですけども
その一つにあのウスターラとかテージャなんていうのがあって
矢という生き物を殺したり
まあ戦争したりする時に使う道具だと思うんですが
ここにこういう例を出されたというのは何か意図があるんでしょうかね
何の意図もないんです
ただ見たから見た通りに書いた
ですか  そこまで考える必要ないんです
なんかもうちょっと別の例えを出した方がよかったかなと思って
いやいや 矢を作るためにどれほど技術必要なのかということでしょ
はい でもなんか  だから矢を作る場合は木の枝を買ってきて
まず水の中に 1ヶ月間ぐらいね
泥の中に入れておいて
それからまっすぐした何かに入れて
ギュッギュッと縛っておいて
それから自然にもう乾くまで待っていて
それでまっすぐなんですけど
それから火にかけたりしてね
また調整して このバネのように動くようにと
それから重さを量ったりして
先にどちらの方が先にするか
どちらの方が矢 羽を作るものにするかとかね
これそう簡単じゃないんです
矢で人殺すかどうか そんな話じゃなくて
矢を作ること自体がすごい技術っていうことなんです
子供にそんな人殺すものだからあんた見るなよって言っちゃうと
普通のおばさんと何が違いますか
あれってひどい男なんです
技術はとことん言うべきなんです
私は子供にはそんなことやらない
そんなこと見るなよって言わないんです
子供は見てはいけないものを知ってはいけない
でも口を挟むと言うんです
私は言います で これ結構成長しますよ
子供はもうあまりも自分に対してわからないや
自分の管轄外やと分かったらまあ興味持たないし
それで問題解決です こちら言おうとしたのにと
言わないでごまかしちゃうと
後でもう大人になってから
それはこの嫌なんですね
だから突然子供っていうのは
もう大人びっくりする
もうどう答えるべきか分からないものを聞いたりしますよ
私の質問を出してる どんな子供でも何の事でも答える
そうしますと正しい職業というか
正しい経済活動ということを話す時に
別の場面でという感じになりますか
まあこれそれとこれって合わないでしょうに
これはね なんかアイスクリームに味噌かけるような話ですよね
アイスクリームには味噌はかけませんよ
だからって味噌は人間食べられ食べられないまずいものって意味じゃないんです
味噌は別な食べ物を食べるんであって
アイスクリームは別な
シロップかけても味噌はかけませんと
いうことで こちらは技術のことを調教のことを言ってるんです
いかに人殺すか 動物殺すかって話じゃないんです
はい そういうことで まあ関係ないってことですね
あ すいません 技術を身につけるっていうのも心の訓練ですよね
うん だから全て心ですよ
例えば走ってマラソンに参加しようと思って毎日走る訓練するでしょうに
それも結局肉体訓練じゃないんです
心の訓練なんです 心があるんだから
肉体は強くなって成長するんです
心がなければもう成長しませんね
だから肉体が生きてるでしょ
ということ 心があるってことなんですね
肉体が生きてるんだから
じゃあ毎日練習するぞと決めるでしょうに
それでもいくら痛くても
いくら疲れても とにかく決まった練習はすると
それで生きてる肉体はその心に合わせてどんどん成長していく
だからもうマラソンの訓練さえも心の訓練だと思った方がよろしいんです
勉強することとか 数学の解決することだけ心の訓練で
それはただ理論の訓練だけでしょうに
理論やら理解やら物覚え
それは一部なんですね
それが心というわけじゃなくて
それが心の一部ですね
だから技術であろうか
もう稽古事であろうか
普通に学ぶことであろうか
何でも心の訓練だとした方が正しいんです
体が単なる物体だと思ってしまえば分かりやすいと思いますね
我々の体がただ椅子 机
柱のような電信柱のような
ただの物体であると 電信柱には何の成長もないでしょう
そのまんまで 自然にもう破壊していくだけ
体は物体です 体も自然には破壊していく
しかし 体は生きているんですね
それを心ということですね
だから生きている体には成長がありますよ
肉体的にも 電信柱にも全然成長がないんですね
その差は心の差なんです
だからそれもよく覚えてほしいポイントなんですよ
肉体に対しては単純に物体であるとしっかりした方がいいのです
たったの物体です それから
たったの物体なんですけど
この違いは何なのかと言えば
それ全て心の世界です
ただの物体は勝手に動けませんね
机はいくら頼んでも勝手には動けません
しかし この物体は動く勝手に
それが心ですね だから心臓の鼓動やら細胞の振動やらも全て心の働きというふうに
それが心というよりは心という働きであると
そうすると働きたくさんあります
それをまとめて ただ集合名詞として心というのです
心臓の動きも心ということなのです
そういうことで 体が単純な物体というふうに理解しておけば
心というのは結構大したもんだなと分かります
それで心はやっぱり偉大なりと分かるんですよ
そこら辺に捨てている石一個っていうのは
あまり偉大なるでも何でもないでしょうね
ただの石ということになるでしょう
しかし 自分の体を見るとそうじゃないんですね
石と違ってすごいことを色んなことをやって成長までしている
それ全て心という働きです
はい それで他の質問がありますか？なければ
はい はい  八方の八正道の説明のところの正思惟のところで
欲に絡む思考 怒りに絡む思考
加害的な思考はストップしなさいということでしたが
例えば武道とか格闘技などは
空手とか柔道とか剣道とかボクシングとかキックボクシングとか
そういったのはスポーツといえども
根っこのところに加害的な思考も含むのかなと思ってしまったんですけど
仏教から見てそういうのは加害的な思考でやるのも見るのも好ましくないとか
それとも単にただスポーツとして見ればいいのかということをお聞きしたいんですけれども
それはね そもそも個人の気持ち次第じゃないかなと思いますけどね
昔はそれは人を殺すために使ったものだから
もう明らかに悪いんですね
今は武道っていうのは一つのスポーツになってるでしょ
だから そんなに悪行為とはいえませんだけど
善行為でもありませんしね
スポーツで善行為ってちょっと言いにくいところもありますけどね
しかしね スポーツマンとしてボクシングやるといっても
本人はもう勝ちたいでしょうにね
それだったらいかに相手を倒すかということも考えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうしね
いかに早くダメージ与えるのかというね
そういう風に考えると悪いんですよ
だからそれは個人の気持ち次第になるんじゃないかなと
で 普遍的な道徳として見ると
この互い いわゆる加害的な思考ということでまとめて理解した方が分かりやすいんです
で まあ人を家に放火したりとかね
よく日本でやることでしょう
もう突然どこか誰か放火したりとか
それは恐ろしい思考ですね
テロリストはもう明確にもうたくさん人を殺したいという
そういうふうに テロリストだけじゃなくて
テロリストを処分する側も
もうとにかく殺したいというね
気持ちでいくし そういう思考で人類は破滅になるんでしょうし
これではもう正しい思考じゃないんですね
とにかくそれで何も得られませんだからね
加害思考では破壊しか何も得られません
堕落しか得られません
これで真理に達するとか
もう他宗教で言っているように天国に行けるとか
これあり得ないんです
そういうことで ただ一般的に理解した方がいいんですよ
個別で言ってくると ちょっとどちらにしようかなと困るとこはあることはあります
別に困らない 困る必要ないんだけど
おっしゃった通りにどうしようか
そういうね もうそういう武道系のスポーツはと
まあそれは気持ち次第ですね
で 空手でまあ自分を鍛えすると
そこでもう同列のレベルの人々を互いにもう力比べをして
じゃあ私は勝ったぞとかぐらいで楽しく終わればね
まあそんなに加害的な思考っていうこともないでしょうしね
だからその場合は堂々と戦うことだから
向こうはこちらに殴るわ
こちらは向こうに殴るわというね
殴らなきゃ成り立たない
ボクシングの場合はね
だから殴られてもなんだこりゃと思わないでしょ
だからボクシングでクタクタやられた人は
もうあいつは私に対してすごい害を与えた
訴えてやるぞってことはまるっきりないんですね
まあ強かったなということぐらいで終わっちゃうんでしょ
だから肉体には損害があっても
その場合は精神には損害入ってないんですね
気持ち的には しかし 例えばボクシングでね
規則を破ったりしちゃうと
その場合は罪は明らかにもう加害ですね
もしボクサーがどうやって
あの人なんて言います？ 審判は？ ジャッジは？ 審判
審判 で その人の目を盗んでどうやって違法的なパンチできるかどうかね
そういう訓練するならば
もう明確に悪行為 罪ですね
やはり決まりを守って正々堂々と戦う場合は
相手がもう敵じゃないんですね
[背景音]相手がいるんだからこそ試合が成り立つっていうことになりますね
だから心次第ですよ 罪は決めるのはいつでも心ですよ
どう見ても心だけ物質的に判断するものじゃないんです
ただそこでボクシングとかも相手を殴るって言った時に
やっぱりその意志一途なというものが絶対に相手を殴るっていう時に働くんで
それはボクサーから聞かない限り
私には何とも言えませんよ
慈しみの心では人を殴るということはできないと思うんですよ
だから俗世間のことだから
慈しみじゃなくて金儲けに行っているでしょうに
だから お医者さんの金儲けとは違いますでしょうね
仏教徒ならそんなに格闘技で金儲けこともないかもしれませんし
また逆にその方が早いと思うよ
タイタイでもよくやっているでしょうしね
子供たちは小さい時からものすごい喜んで訓練するしね
タイボクシングのはもっと怖いでしょ
でもそういう仏教の国だから
結構みんなお互い殴り合いやりながら
みんな兄弟みたいな感じでお互い心配して
もう可愛いんです 見てみると
だから 一人一人が自分の技術を身に着くことで精一杯で
まあそんなに厳密に私に聞いたってもね
やっぱりそこは気持ちをその本人に聞かないとね
ボクサーに聞かない どんな気持ちで殴るのかと
そんなこと考える余裕がないと
今自分がポイントを取ることだけなんですよ
一つ当たったらポイントを一つ取ってますからね
だからみんなポイントのことしか考えていないと思いますよ
レスリングしたっても
相手をピンダウンすることしか考えてないんです
殴らなくてできれば殴らないでピンダウンすることをするんです
怪我させよう 怪我させようじゃなくて
とにかくピンダウンするぞっていうことだけ
柔道でも同じことでしょうし
ポイント取るんですね
1本とか まあ慈しみの世界ではないかもしれませんだけど
そんな悪の世界ともね
ちょっと言い切れませんね
実際 罪になるかならないかということは
その それやってる本人の気持ちを見ない限りは分かりません
一般論では言えません
母親が子供を殴ったら
これ罪だよとか どうやって決めますかね
それはもう本人の心次第ですからね